et puis avant de nous quitter je vous
propose de revenir sur la soirée d'hier
à la foire aux vins de colmar
ils étaient très nombreux à venir
applaudir sylvie vartan le hasard fait
souvent bien les choses elle est la
marraine de la 50e édition de la foire
est elle aussi fait son anniversaire 53
ans demain l'accueil du public colmarien
était sans doute le plus beau cadeau
qu'on puisse offrir à une chanteuse
regardez pour son huitième passage à la
foire aux vins de colmar depuis 1963
sylvie vartan a attiré hier soir plus de
6000 fans de tous les âges
la longévité à du mans
c'est vrai que colmar est un endroit où
je suis passé très souvent et j'en ai
gardé toujours un souvenir excellent
d'un public très enthousiaste chaleureux
qui ont plus la région est aussi très
accueillante beaucoup d'autres raisons
de la californie j'ai planté ma vie en
35 ans de carrière l'exclu gènes du
twist qu'il n'est plus de 500 chansons
et son spectacle à l'américaine très pro
elle vit à los angeles et un va et vient
entre l'époque didier et son nouveau
répertoire où jean louis murat à luc
plamandon ici montrichard chetaille la
partager
et la sortie tout droit en bande
dessinée
il soulève
le cinéma
on a toujours l'impression que vous
naviguez entre le présent et la
nostalgie maintenant parce que j'ai un
côté certainement que nostalgique c'est
vrai est grave mais je n'ai aucune
nostalgie pour le temps passé parce que
je vis le moment présent toujours quand
je pense après ce que j'ai fait c'est
vrai que ça donne un peu le vertige
surtout que j'ai vécu des périodes de
très fortes puis cette amitié
émotionnellement haut placé
moi j'en ai fait des foires vous savez
l'histoire
l' espoir de maubeuge les bêtises de
cambrai j'en ai fait des choses oui oh
non non c'est en général très gai comme
ambiance
enfin